obviously i'm sure you've been thinking
about doing a movie for a little while
um
how much did you debate what you wanted
to be for your first project knowing
that you know it's a really big deal
what you take on for your first movie
yeah totally there's there's absolutely
that thing in your mind of like you only
get to make your first feature once
right and uh and being totally honest i
think if you told me your first feature
is going to be a whodunit uh i would
have said oh are you sure because i
wouldn't have like considered myself a
huge fan of the whodunnit i liked the
genre and uh you know was a big fan of
um
you know murder mystery novels in my
youth but it wasn't something i was like
itching to make but when i read mark's
script
and
saw that it was both
a murder mystery but also a film that's
about murder mysteries and the way that
they function and the tropes that they
rely on
um and also at its heart
as character comedy about these two
unlikely detective partners coming
together and whether they can come
together and crack the case
you know it was those things that um
that got me excited about it and and
felt like i could um
could uh do it in a way that's hopefully
uh successful obviously covet is the
worst and it's the i mean it's terrible
but
it did lead you guys to being able to
use like these great locations that you
would have never gotten otherwise can
you sort of talk about that yeah that
was a uh strange silver lining to the
whole
process of filming during carving was
that
we were able to film in some of these
incredible locations in london
um that we would never have been able to
get into to to film at you know so
places like the old vic where we spent
four or five days filming on the stage
and in the auditorium
you know under normal circumstances you
might be able to get in there for a
couple of hours to film something you
know at the end of the day
um
of course it was bittersweet because
the all these theaters were their doors
were closed and we didn't know at that
point when they were coming back and in
what form they'd be coming back
but um
you know being able to contribute to
them in the in that you know by hiring
them as a location during that period
um
was nice and it's really special that
there are places like the old vic and
the savoy hotel and the dominion theater
as well as a bunch of exterior locations
in and around central london
that we um have managed to to bring to
the big screen and and
uh yeah i feel very lucky to have been
able to do that yeah it's also what
people don't realize is just add so much
production value you know for you don't
have to build anything you're just using
actual london is just you walk around
the streets it looks like 1950.
completely and there's a whole mix of
that in this film there's you know pure
straight up location work with a little
bit of dressing you know to or a bit of
a light visual effects to remove modern
elements there's studio build stuff like
um the one that stands out is mervyn's
apartment which which is a incredible
studio build done by um
our production designer amanda mcarthur
and her team
and then in the middle there are my kind
of my favorite which is to find a
location and then build into it to
create a space that
works exactly how you want it to work
and that's what we found with um
scotland yard um the police headquarters
there which was actually a kind of uh
school dining hall this beautiful
old
school dining hall with original
features in on the outskirts of north
london
and we were then able to sort of build
in to build the office spaces and and
put in the lighting that sort of really
took you back to that era and created
that kind of atmosphere um so it was an
amazing world to be able to create from
a design point of view i'm always
curious about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together so what did you learn from any
friends and family screenings or test
screenings that actually impacted the
finished film yeah we had a couple of um
preview screenings um the first of which
in particular was really informative in
terms of particularly when you have a
mystery plot and you need to make sure
that your revelations the information
you're dropping is is not too much but
enough you know
if you don't see those breadcrumbs
sufficiently when the reveal comes the
audience feels short-changed somehow
because they wouldn't they don't feel
they could have ever you know
followed that thread on their own
um
and of course like equally bad is them
getting ahead of the plot and sort of
figuring it out well before you're ready
to reveal it in your film so it was
really really useful in terms of a bunch
of fresh eyes to watch and tell us
when and where they were on to certain
um
certain reveals um that was that was
hugely helpful the other thing that
reshaped um
after our first preview was the opening
of the film we were always conscious
that the first act or even the sort of
um
re-first act of a murder mystery is a
tricky
period in the story because typically
and in our film your detectives haven't
arrived yet and when your detectives
arrive and when they arrive in our film
everything becomes clear in terms of
like tone and you have a point of view
and you have characters pushing you
through the story so it's how to do the
sort of opening before the detectives
arrive before the murder has occurred
how do you present the
um introduce the audience to this world
of characters
um in a way that's economical but also
feels like it has a point of view a
clear point of view to it um and when we
increased um the influence in that first
in the opening of adrian brody's
character
increased the amount of voice over that
he had in that and made him made the
whole sort of opening circle around his
character it kind of unlocked it for us
and that was something that we we only
found post that initial preview uh did
you end up with like a lot of deleted
scenes or a longer cut of the film or is
it pretty much what we see
no there was a longer cut of the film um
[Music]
mostly the things that haven't made it
into the film were because we're from a
story point of view i think once you
in a thriller my feeling is once you get
to a certain point whether that be the
midpoint of the film or maybe into the
third act
um
you're into what i would call the spiral
then and everything needs to be
accelerating and taking you forward and
pushing you on and on and on
and
so it was really in terms of that um
story
economy and keeping it as sharp as
possible and seeing scenes that we liked
in isolation but that was slightly
repeating a story beat or
circling the same thematic point
um
it was um i actually worked with two
editors on the film and um
i started off with a guy called peter
lambert who
did incredible work and then due to
scheduling issues had to step off the
film
um and
um gary donner came on to complete the
film now fortunately they had very much
the same taste had worked on very
similar stuff throughout their career
um so that was a an easy transition
but actually it was great in that back
end of the edit having um gary come in
and
and look at some of those scenes that
i'm talking about that ultimately didn't
make it into the car with fresh eyes and
with none of that um sense of the the
sunk costs that have gone into uh you
know you get attached to scenes
because you know what they took to shoot
but also because you know what they took
to edit you know to get this working
really nicely as a sequence in its own
right you you feel
like you want to get in the movie if you
possibly can so it's great having gary
come in with fresh eyes and saying this
isn't moving the story forward at this
point let's see how it functions
without it and you know it's non-linear
editing can always go back in nobody's
out with scissors and film anymore so um
yeah it was it was great
and um i always feel like a film's got a
fighting way to be honest that it's
trying to get to and i always felt like
this film would be at its best around an
hour 45 an hour 40 minutes and it took
us a while to get there but um but i i
think it got to where it wanted to be as
a story uh last thing for you real quick
um you put together this great cast for
your debut film um who was the person or
two that you couldn't believe signed on
oh my goodness i mean
the list just goes on and on you know
cersei was the first person we went out
to for constable stalker like she said
yes then we managed to get sam rockwell
to
play stop hard and the thought of those
two together was enough that's fine we
can have unknowns in the rest of the
movie from that point on so then david
yellow and adrian brody and ruth wilson
and then the chance to
incorporate some of my favorite um
british comic actors uh into that
ensemble
it just means that right the way down
that cast list
um there are uh
incredible
actors who i'm a huge fan was a huge fan
of many of them beforehand and getting
the chance to bring them all together
and work with them in this um crazy
ensemble was uh
was yeah a dream come true
uh yeah and as far as the scenes you cut
out that's why they have a blu-rays
that's why they have blu-rays exactly
exactly exactly that's why yeah
i mean look but seriously um listen i
gotta stop
i'm just gonna say congrats on the movie
i hope that um it's a huge hit for you
and you're making something else soon
thank you so much really appreciate the
time really enjoyed this
you